>>> IFWHE
VACCINATED PEOPLE L BANNED
FROM LIVG
A?
PHYSICALONCTOESN'T WORK AND
THEY'RE SIMPLY N T
>> TUCKER CARLSON ISNENY
IN THE RIGHT-WING MEDIA CASTNINO
NS CONE P T',
W T PAGE.I K I HE KNOW S LIKER
EY?
LTIMATELY BECOMEREVE THE NAME OE
LIS
JOURNALISM.
OT NEWS.
INGANDA.
JUST LAST WEEK, NEWENT UCORDING
PLO BSOLUTELS  IT
N'
I MEAN, COME ON.
ANYBODY WHO DISPUTES THAT SORT
OF STUFF IS PUG
LIVES AT RISK D KILLING THEMO Q
STDI.
ISN'T KILLING YOUR OWN
SUPPORTERS A BAD
UTELY.
E
THIS IS LIRAY THMIS NN
SLAUGHTER. T INSTEAD
OF THE SCIH ESAY WE WOULD NOT B
FON SILLIN.
THESE THINGS ARE REAL. SUGGE,
RTF YOU
EDUCATIOCE, IT'SYIN PEOPLE AND
E F
SOV I ATETHE OLPID OWS HOW SICO
BEOIHI PEOHES FOX, OR ERT WORK,.
ESLS
PERPETUATING LIES.
I'ING HARD.E IN PERFECT SITUATI
WITH ARGITUTIONS, ACTIVISTS ACR
THE COUNTRY. AN INCREDIBLY D OU
UNDERSTA THAT WHLICAN PARTY AND
AND 'SE FOTHLEFT
MOT FIGH
THE WAY REPUBLICS .E'
YERACEOUR YEARS.'S7 ON THESIDE,P
STORIES, TRYIN
HALF OF THE COUNTRONFT-HAND SID
TO
DISEASE AND WE'RAND WEEED A LOT.
KEEY, TIME
BEEN DOING IALE WAE
THE YEAR FOR
THE UPOSNGRESSIONAL RACES, AND
WHITE HOUSE THARS FROM
NOW.
>>T OF A THAT YOU AND OTHERS W
TH THEY SEEM
SO YET KNOW MILLIONS
D
.YS WON Y KNO
I WOUL WHEN ITTO THE KD OF DRILT
IS COMING OUOU THINK HOSE LAUR
T CORONAWITH ORY VES C TUTI GO
IBLE TO ME TH W
THEY'RE DOING FOR HEO INRM UNIT
AMERICA.E HYPOCRISY OF IANTH
THAT TRUMP STARTED VINGS EXACTL
EVEN BEFORE HE WAS ELECTED.
>> AND TO THAT POINT
IEE FA  I
JANUARY.
HEAKON
WHENOUTO YOUERGUES AX OU WERE EF
COMPLICITORG ED
THEIRD   EYEBALL.DSAN
AND ALL THEYEAO IS
E WATCHING UNTILD THEN
, CA-CHINGE NETWORK.
IT NEWS.
PEOPLEN
BEEN
HO HAVNDOMGOOD JOUIS HAVE
COMPANY  BUTF LENTED PEOPLE HAV
>>T SUAI WATCH SOME OF
WHAT'SH WHAT A
IT'S GROANY.TO
COTRS TOHAVE A
CONVERSATION AGAIN.
TI T, AMILWH
YOED ONE EMMAKEU'RE
WORRIED ABOUT EI
LUSIONED ON'LLNDE
D DON'Tnd IT
IT'S NOT THE
PRESIDT.E , OU
EE
THEAST UR.  SUCH